May 25th is the one-year anniversary of the murder of George Floyd by Minneapolis police officer Derek Chauvin, a shocking crime captured on video that horrified America. It also sparked months of protests and brought new urgency to long-standing anger over police violence against black men and women in the United States. In April, Chauvin was convicted of two counts of murder and one count of manslaughter. He faces sentencing in June. While the verdict brought some sense of justice and relief for many, it did not change the dynamic. of racial bias that was a factor in Floyd's death. Police reform remains a top priority for many Americans.
5月25日是明尼阿波利斯警官德里克·肖万谋杀乔治·弗洛伊德的一周年纪念日，这起令人震惊的罪行被视频记录下来，震惊了全美。它也引发了长达数月的抗议活动，并使美国民众对针对黑人男性和女性的警察暴力行为长期以来的愤怒变得更加紧迫。4月，肖万被判两项谋杀罪和一项过失杀人罪成立。他将于6月面临判刑。虽然这一判决为许多人带来了一些正义感和宽慰，但它并没有改变导致弗洛伊德死亡的种族偏见这一动态。警察改革仍然是许多美国人的首要任务。
President Biden has urged Congress to pass the George Floyd Justice in Policing Act, which would make it easier for people to sue law enforcement officers in civil court. It would also ban chokeholds, direct police departments to use body and dashboard cameras and require police officers to learn and use de-escalation techniques. But are these changes enough? If not, what else do we need? What would effective police reform look like? police reform look like, and what can be done to restore the trust between police departments
拜登总统敦促国会通过《乔治·弗洛伊德警务公正法案》，该法案将使人们更容易在民事法庭起诉执法人员。它还将禁止锁喉，指导警察部门使用随身摄像头和行车记录仪，并要求警官学习和使用降级冲突的技术。但这些改变足够了吗？如果不够，我们还需要什么？有效的警察改革会是什么样子？警察改革会是什么样子，以及可以做些什么来恢复警察部门与他们所服务的社区，特别是少数族裔社区之间的信任。
and the communities that they serve, especially people of color communities. Psychological research has contributed insights into these questions which we will discuss today. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Nils. Our guest today is Dr. Cedric Alexander, a psychologist with decades of experience in both mental health and law enforcement. He began his career as a police officer and detective in Florida in the 1970s and 80s. After more than a decade in law enforcement, he earned a doctorate in clinical psychology and worked as a mental health practitioner and an assistant professor
心理学研究为这些问题提供了见解，我们今天将进行讨论。欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·尼尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是塞德里克·亚历山大博士，他是一位在心理健康和执法领域拥有数十年经验的心理学家。他于20世纪70年代和80年代在佛罗里达州开始了他的职业生涯，担任警官和侦探。在执法部门工作了十多年后，他获得了临床心理学博士学位，并担任心理健康从业者和心理学助理教授。
of psychology at the University of Rochester. In 2002, he returned to policing as deputy chief of police in Rochester, New York. He later served as Rochester's police chief, deputy commissioner of the New York State Division of Criminal Justice Services, Federal Security Directorial director at the Dallas Fort Worth International Airport and Director of Public Safety for DeKalb County, Georgia. He is also a past president of the National Organization of Black Law Enforcement Executives. In 2015, he was a member of President Obama's Task Force on 21st Century Policing, which issued a report and recommendations that we'll also talk about today. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Alexander. Thank you for having me. Thank you very much. So let's start by
在罗切斯特大学任教。2002年，他重返警界，担任纽约州罗切斯特市的副警察局长。后来，他担任了罗切斯特市警察局长、纽约州刑事司法服务部副专员、达拉斯-沃斯堡国际机场联邦安全主任以及佐治亚州迪卡尔布县公共安全主任。他还是全国黑人执法高管组织的前任主席。2015年，他是奥巴马总统“21世纪警务工作组”的成员，该工作组发布了一份报告和建议，我们今天也将讨论这些内容。感谢您今天加入我们，亚历山大博士。谢谢您的邀请。非常感谢。那么让我们从
talking about President Obama's task force on 21st century policing. It convened in 2015 after the shooting of Michael Brown in Ferguson, Missouri. What were the major recommendations of the task force, and now six years later, have any of its recommendations been implemented? Well, there were six pillars to that document that we were directed by President Obama at that time to come up with as a roadmap to help develop relationships between police and community, which, was at another moment of one of those very historic all-time lows. So myself and 10 other individuals who were noted in the law enforcement community, civil rights community, and academia, you name it.
谈论奥巴马总统的“21世纪警务工作组”开始。它是在2015年密苏里州弗格森市迈克尔·布朗被枪杀后召集的。工作组的主要建议是什么？现在六年过去了，其中的任何建议是否得到了实施？嗯，当时奥巴马总统指示我们制定的那份文件有六大支柱，作为帮助发展警察与社区之间关系的路线图，当时正处于历史最低谷的时刻之一。所以，我和其他10位在执法界、民权界、学术界等领域享有盛誉的人士，
We were brought together by the White House and was given that charge by President Obama at that time. And we had 60 days to come up with some recommendations, which we delivered to him on March 2nd, I believe it was 2015. But Six Pillars, we established, we had a number of listening sessions across this country, listening to people from all walks of life, from education, human rights, civil rights, unions, you name it. Everyone in this nation had an opportunity to come before us either in person or via social media or they could write in, call in,
被白宫召集在一起，并接受了奥巴马总统当时的指派。我们有60天的时间来提出一些建议，我相信是在2015年3月2日提交给他的。但是，我们确立了六大支柱，我们在全国各地举行了多次听证会，倾听来自各行各业的人们的声音，包括教育、人权、民权、工会等等。这个国家的每个人都有机会通过当面、社交媒体、书信或电话的方式来到我们面前，
and leave their thoughts, ideas, and suggestions to how to move this country forward and create a relationship, or begin to create a relationship between police and community that would have some influence in terms of changing. Many of the attitudes of people in our community and the long history of abuse, which people have experience, and the disconnect between police and community that has been longstanding, particularly communities of color. So the document employed, and one particular was trust in legitimacy, which is pillar one and probably one of the most important pillars of that document. Because without a police department being seen as being legitimate, you cannot have trust. And if you cannot have trust, then you cannot have good public safety in any community.
留下他们的想法、意见和建议，以推动这个国家向前发展，并建立一种关系，或者开始建立一种警察与社区之间的关系，这种关系将在改变我们社区中许多人的态度以及人们所经历的长期虐待历史，以及警察与社区之间长期存在的脱节（特别是少数族裔社区）方面产生影响。因此，该文件采用了，其中一个特别重要的是信任与合法性，这是第一支柱，也是该文件最重要的支柱之一。因为如果一个警察部门不被视为合法的，你就无法拥有信任。如果没有信任，那么在任何社区都不可能有良好的公共安全。
And then there was other pieces in that document as well that talked about offers of wellness and officers being mentally and physically and psychologically capable of carrying out their functions and making sure as a community we provided them police officers with support that they need to do oftentimes what is a very difficult job. So a lot of information grew out of that. One in particular was body cameras. Body cameras became popularized as a result of the 21st century task force report. Body cameras was a way really to help build that trust.
文件中还有其他部分谈到了警官的健康，以及警官在心理、生理和心理上是否有能力履行其职能，并确保作为一个社区，我们为警官提供他们执行通常是非常困难的工作所需的支持。因此，很多信息由此产生。其中特别重要的一项是随身摄像头。随身摄像头因21世纪工作组的报告而普及。随身摄像头确实是一种帮助建立信任的方式。
to really, so the public can see as much as they could as to what occurred based on the statements that were made by officers or witnesses or persons who might have been involved in that event altogether. And body cameras, that technology is very evident today. Many departments across the country employ body cameras. There are still a few who don't, but many do, particularly in your larger metropolitan communities. but they can be expensive, not just for the camera itself, but the storage of the information over time. But I think many municipalities and cities and states and counties are just beginning
真正地，让公众能够尽可能多地看到基于警官、证人或可能参与该事件的人员所作陈述而发生的事情。随身摄像头，这项技术在今天非常明显。全国许多部门都使用随身摄像头。虽然仍有一些部门不使用，但许多部门都在使用，特别是在大型都市社区。但它们可能很昂贵，不仅是摄像头本身，还有随着时间的推移对信息的存储。但我认为许多市政当局、城市、州和县才刚刚开始
to understand the importance of having this technology available. Other things that came out of that, of course, was agencies that evolved in office-involved shootings. It became important that those agencies did not investigate themselves and their own personnel, but there was opportunity for other law enforcement agencies, preferably an agency that was above that agency in terms of government. So if a city police department was involved in a shooting, it was always encouraged that state, the state law enforcement agency would be an investigative body so that you can maintain a sense of independence and transparency in that investigation, which allowed to public to feel a sense of fairness in doing those investigations. And that that agency that was involved in the shooting was being
了解拥有这项技术的重要性。当然，由此产生的其他事情是涉及警官枪击事件的机构。重要的是，这些机构不能调查自己及其人员，而是有机会让其他执法机构，最好是政府层级高于该机构的机构进行调查。因此，如果一个城市警察局涉及枪击事件，总是鼓励由州执法机构作为调查机构，以便在调查中保持独立性和透明度，这使公众在进行这些调查时感到一种公平感。而且那个涉及枪击事件的机构是
open and transparent and favoritism was not being given, rather it was real or perceived. So there was just numerous recommendations that were made. In fact, that document is still up online. If you just Google 21st Century Task Force final report, it will still pop up and you will see a great deal of work that went into that document that provided police agencies with a lot of ideas and some things they already knew and some things that were new to help guide them along the way. And of course, after the Obama administration, when the next administration came in, they had a very different approach, quite different. But many police departments across the country still utilize that document, have utilized it since it
公开透明的，没有偏袒，无论是真实的还是感知的。所以提出了许多建议。事实上，该文件仍然可以在网上找到。如果你在谷歌上搜索“21世纪工作组最终报告”，它仍然会弹出，你会看到投入到该文件中的大量工作，这些工作为警察机构提供了许多想法，其中一些是他们已经知道的，一些是新的，以帮助指导他们前进。当然，在奥巴马政府之后，当下一届政府上台时，他们采取了非常不同的方法，截然不同。但全国许多警察部门仍然利用该文件，自
was published in 2015, and it certainly can serve as a guide and a roadmap to help us building trust and legitimacy with our communities and with our police agencies across the country. One of the pillars in that report was to build trust and support by police departments, as you said, by being open and transparent. What does that mean in real life and are police departments willing to go along with that recommendation? Well, if you want to have successful public safety, And since the beginning, and the father of law enforcement, of public safety, of policing, Sir Robert P.O., who was a home secretary in London at the time, created the first police department. And his premise was very simple. The community is the police and the police is the community. And you fast forward that now over 150 years later. And what you will find is, is the police.
2015年发布以来一直在使用它，它当然可以作为帮助我们与社区以及全国各地的警察机构建立信任和合法性的指南和路线图。报告中的支柱之一是正如你所说，通过公开透明来建立警察部门的信任和支持。这在现实生活中意味着什么？警察部门是否愿意配合这一建议？嗯，如果你想拥有成功的公共安全。而且从一开始，公共安全和警务之父，当时的伦敦内政大臣罗伯特·皮尔爵士，创建了第一个警察部门。他的前提非常简单。社区就是警察，警察就是社区。现在快进150多年。你会发现，警察
that no community is safe unless you have community and police working together. If they're separate from each other, if they're conflict with each other, police are not capable of doing their jobs in order to protect and to serve a community at large. And communities will not be safe without trained professionals who are there to take bad people off the road and, more importantly, to prevent crime, even before it gets to that place. So if you don't have trust between the public and the community, police departments become delegitimized. And I can give a police officer all the authority in the world to carry a weapon,
如果没有社区和警察的共同努力，任何社区都是不安全的。如果他们彼此分离，如果他们彼此冲突，警察就无法履行职责，以保护和为整个社区服务。如果没有受过训练的专业人员在那里将坏人赶出道路，更重要的是，在犯罪发生之前就预防犯罪，社区就不会安全。因此，如果公众和社区之间没有信任，警察部门就会失去合法性。我可以给一名警官世界上所有的权力去携带武器，
to take someone to freedom, to even take their life. This is justifiable. But what I cannot give you as a police officer is legitimacy. That comes from the community. they have to give you legitimacy. That means that they have to feel they can trust you. They have to feel that they can be heard and listen to. They have to feel a sense of connectedness with their local law enforcement agency. And they have to feel they have a department that is open and transparent. And they work together as a team. Police departments can no longer work as this clandestine operation that is apart from the community.
去剥夺某人的自由，甚至夺走他们的生命。这是正当的。但我作为一名警官不能给你的是合法性。这来自社区。他们必须给你合法性。这意味着他们必须感到他们可以信任你。他们必须感到他们可以被倾听。他们必须感到与当地执法机构有一种联系感。他们必须感到他们拥有一个公开透明的部门。他们像一个团队一样工作。警察部门不能再作为这种脱离社区的秘密行动来运作。
You have to be very much a part of community, and this is what community is demanding. And to be perfectly honest with you, this is what we should have been doing from the beginning. But we lost our way in this. But we're in a very, very different time in the history of this nation that is very diverse, not in terms of just the obvious of race and gender, but diverse in the terms of how we think and see and feel and cognitively, I should say, experience this world. And everyone sees it very, very differently. And for anyone that's a city leader or police leader in that community, you really have to be an individual who understands the dynamics of diversity and be respectful of it at all levels. if you're going to be a strong leader, a good leader, a credible leader, a legitimate leader to the people in which you serve.
你必须非常深入地成为社区的一部分，这就是社区所要求的。老实说，这正是我们从一开始就应该做的。但我们在这方面迷失了方向。但我们正处于这个国家历史上一个非常、非常不同的时期，这个国家非常多元化，不仅仅是在种族和性别的明显方面，而且在我们的思维、观察、感受以及我应该说在认知上体验这个世界的方式上也是多元化的。每个人看待它的方式都非常、非常不同。对于任何一个城市领导者或社区警察领导者来说，你真的必须是一个了解多样性动态并尊重各个层面多样性的人。如果你想成为一名强大的领导者、优秀的领导者、可信的领导者、对你所服务的人民合法的领导者。
So you've just given pretty much the definition of community policing, and I know you're a strong advocate of that as a practice. Are there some communities you could name that have been successful in this respect? Can you give us some examples of who's doing it right at this point? Well, it's not a matter or so much of naming any particular community. I think all communities struggle with it. You know, if you're Mayberry RFD and you got an Andy Griffin and you got a Barney Fife and everybody knows everybody in that small little half a square mile, a quarter of a square mile community, that's a beautiful thing, right?
所以你刚才几乎给出了社区警务的定义，我知道你是这种做法的坚定倡导者。你能说出一些在这方面取得成功的社区吗？你能给我们举一些目前做得对的例子吗？嗯，这与其说是命名任何特定社区的问题。我认为所有社区都在为此挣扎。你知道，如果你在梅伯里，你有安迪·格里芬，你有巴尼·法伊夫，在这个半平方英里、四分之一平方英里的社区里，每个人都认识每个人，那是一件美好的事情，对吧？
That would be great. But unfortunately, oftentimes it does not work that way in many of our communities across this country. Now, I don't say that that does not exist, but in most cases, and certainly the communities that we come across in those that are oftentimes troubled or run into these predicaments that create a great deal of angst across the nation. There is no one particular department that's doing it right. Everybody is in a trial and error place. Everyone is struggling. There are days we do it very well.
那会很棒。但不幸的是，在全国许多社区，情况往往并非如此。现在，我并不是说这种情况不存在，但在大多数情况下，当然是我们遇到的那些经常陷入困境或陷入这些在全国范围内造成极大焦虑的困境的社区。没有哪一个特定的部门做得对。每个人都处于试错阶段。每个人都在挣扎。有些日子我们做得很好。
Then there are days that we struggle. And there are days that community struggle. So it is an ongoing event. but there's no one agency that I can name that is doing a perfect job with it. It is an ongoing everyday trust-building type of relationship. It's like a marriage, if you will. You've got to work on it every day because police departments are there to serve the community. And communities need to be there to be supportive of good policing.
然后有些日子我们挣扎。有些日子社区也在挣扎。所以这是一个持续不断的事件。但没有一个我可以点名的机构在做完美的工作。这是一种持续的、日常的建立信任的关系。如果你愿意的话，这就像婚姻。你必须每天为此努力，因为警察部门的存在是为了服务社区。而社区需要支持良好的警务工作。
The operative word here, good policing. constitutional policing, honest policing, transparent policing. And at the same time, communities must make sure that they do their part in being supportive of the men and women who are out there working to keep all of us safe. You have a unique background in clinical psychology and law enforcement. I mean, that's not something that you run into every day when you meet a police chief. How has your psychology training affected your approach to law enforcement? enforcement? Well, actually, it's been a real benefit to me. I, you know, in my intent, you know, I spent
这里的关键词是，良好的警务。宪法警务、诚实警务、透明警务。同时，社区必须确保他们尽自己的一份力量，支持那些在外面努力工作以保障我们所有人安全的男男女女。你拥有临床心理学和执法方面的独特背景。我的意思是，当你遇到警察局长时，这不是你每天都会遇到的事情。你的心理学训练如何影响了你的执法方法？执法？嗯，实际上，这对我有很大的好处。我，你知道，在我的意图中，你知道，我花了很多
many years in law enforcement. I got out, Kim, with no intent of going back at all when I got out in 1992. We never know what the road's going to lead to, but I can tell you this, having that background experience as a trained psychologist really helped me to better understand large organizations in which I led. When I'm able to bring a group of people into a room, when I'm able to talk with mentor, discipline, encourage, promote, inspire people who worked under my command, having that training as a psychologist really helped me tremendously to evaluate people's strengths in their challenges or weaknesses in helping them to be the very best employee that they can be, not to break people down, but to help build them up. Also helping people come
年从事执法工作。金，我1992年离开时，根本没有回去的打算。我们永远不知道道路会通向哪里，但我可以告诉你，拥有作为受过训练的心理学家的背景经验确实帮助我更好地了解我所领导的大型组织。当我能够把一群人带进一个房间，当我能够与我指挥下工作的人交谈、指导、纪律、鼓励、促进、激励时，拥有心理学家的训练确实对我评估人们的优势和挑战或弱点，帮助他们成为他们能成为的最优秀的员工，而不是打击人们，而是帮助建立他们，有巨大的帮助。也帮助人们做出
to a determination that the work that they were doing was maybe not where their best talents were either. But that is something that we learn how to do as clinicians is to listen and to evaluate and to help people get to the place where they're trying to get to. But as a manager, as an executive, as a leader of a large organization, the training was tremendously helpful in for me to help fix organizations. Oftentimes I went into that were struggling or that were broken. One of the major contributions of psychological research to our understanding of racial disparities in policing and in communities in general, is knowledge about implicit bias, the biases that people have that are outside of their
决定，他们所做的工作可能不是他们最有天赋的地方。但这是我们作为临床医生学习如何做的事情，即倾听、评估并帮助人们到达他们试图到达的地方。但作为一名管理者、一名高管、一名大型组织的领导者，这种训练对我修复组织非常有帮助。我经常进入那些正在挣扎或破碎的组织。心理学研究对我们理解警务和社区中种族差异的主要贡献之一，是关于内隐偏见的知识，即人们在他们的
conscious awareness and maybe control. Some police departments have started to require implicit bias trainings to make officers aware of this phenomenon. I know you're a clinician and a law enforcement executive and not a researcher, but speaking from that perspective, what role do you think implicit bias trainings should play in police departments? Well, I think it's clearly important And we need that training in every aspect of our American institutions, even in the field of psychology itself, even among psychologists, even among journalists, among politicians, among every field of endeavor there is, because we all have implicit biases. And we're all born with these implicit biases. And we well know that in the amygdala, which is one of the most primitive parts of the brain, is where fight and flight lives. And things that we're not familiar with, we have a tendency to either stay in fight or to run.
意识之外，可能无法控制的偏见。一些警察部门已经开始要求进行内隐偏见培训，以使警官意识到这种现象。我知道你是一名临床医生和执法高管，而不是研究人员，但从那个角度来看，你认为内隐偏见培训在警察部门应该发挥什么作用？嗯，我认为这显然很重要。我们需要在我们的美国机构的各个方面进行这种培训，甚至在心理学领域本身，甚至在心理学家、记者、政治家中，在存在的每一个努力领域，因为我们都有内隐偏见。我们生来就有这些内隐偏见。我们很清楚，在杏仁核中，这是大脑中最原始的部分之一，是战斗和逃跑居住的地方。对于我们不熟悉的事情，我们倾向于要么战斗，要么逃跑。
So we take that and we think about it in this very basic and fundamental way. As we grow, as we come into life after birth, we're exposed to a number. number of different things in our environment, things that we learn that are safe, things that we learned that are not safe, things that we hear about people, places, and things that could be a positive value, that could be a negative value, but it feeds into our own psyche. And we can develop these implicit biases. These implicit biases can be reinforced by things we learn in our family of origin, our communities, churches, schools, etc. And I think the most important thing is for those of us who deal with the public,
所以我们接受这一点，并以这种非常基本和根本的方式思考它。随着我们的成长，随着我们出生后进入生活，我们接触到许多不同的事物。在我们的环境中，我们学到的认为是安全的，我们学到的认为是不安全的，我们听到的关于人、地点和事物的信息，可能是正面的价值，也可能是负面的价值，但它会进入我们自己的心理。我们可以发展这些内隐偏见。这些内隐偏见可以通过我们在原生家庭、社区、教堂、学校等中学到的东西得到加强。我认为最重要的事情是对于我们这些与公众打交道的人来说，
whether we're clinicians or whether we're police officers or public safety officials, it is important for all of us to be aware of the fact if we have these implicit, unconscious biases that are going on, it serves the benefit to people we're there to serve and to benefit ourselves if we're aware of those biases. but we have to come to terms with the fact that we all have some biases in some way, right? We like something over something else, and we need to be able to know that and be able to acknowledge it because it's always not in your face, but it's unconsciously. We make decisions about people where our places or things and our biases kick in, and we may not be aware of it.
无论是临床医生还是警官或公共安全官员，重要的是我们所有人都意识到如果我们有这些正在进行的内隐、无意识的偏见，如果我们意识到这些偏见，这对我们所服务的人和我们自己都有好处。但我们必须接受这样一个事实，即我们所有人都有某种偏见，对吧？我们喜欢某样东西胜过另一样东西，我们需要能够知道这一点并能够承认它，因为它并不总是显而易见的，但它是无意识的。我们对人、地点或事物做出决定，我们的偏见就会介入，而我们可能没有意识到。
I may make a statement to you as a woman coming from a man, but not being sensitive to the fact that I'm a baby boomer. And I was raised to believe certain things, right, that could be offensive to you. And but unknowing to me. So the more that we are able to take a look at ourselves inwardly and to make those assessments and to familiarize ourselves with people, places, and things. that may be very unfamiliar to us. We have a tendency to be a lot more conscious and a lot more aware because none of us are perfect human beings. I teach implicit, explicit bias, even though all the data shows that regardless of how much training you do, it really doesn't make it real difference.
我作为一个男人可能会对你作为一个女人发表声明，但没有意识到我是婴儿潮一代。我被抚养长大相信某些事情，对吧，这可能会冒犯你。而且我不知道。所以我们越能够向内审视自己并进行这些评估，并让自己熟悉那些对我们来说可能非常陌生的人、地点和事物，我们就越倾向于更加清醒和更加有意识，因为我们没有人是完美的人类。我教授内隐、外显偏见，尽管所有数据都表明，无论你进行多少培训，它真的不会产生真正的差异。
So even in my training, I know this going in. But here's what I encourage people to do. in spite of what the literature says, and I think it's important to pay attention to the literature, but here's what I tend to do, is for people to have their own, to go inside themselves and ask themselves those very tough questions. They have their own process. What I don't do in my class, Kim, is point out someone who may be white, part of the majority group. Well, tell me what you did to that person. When you do that, people become defensive. People come already in being defensive, right? Oh, I'm going to get hit over the head for being part of the majority group in this country. And when people cannot be comfortable, when people cannot feel like they're going, if people are going to feel like they're going to be attacked in one of these classes because of the ethnic group that they belong to, then people cannot learn.
所以即使在我的培训中，我也知道这一点。但我鼓励人们做的是，尽管文献怎么说，我认为关注文献很重要，但我倾向于做的是，让人们拥有自己的，深入内心并问自己那些非常棘手的问题。他们有自己的过程。金，我在课堂上不做的是指出某个可能是白人、属于多数群体的人。好吧，告诉我你对那个人做了什么。当你这样做时，人们会变得防御。人们已经带着防御心理来了，对吧？哦，我要因为作为这个国家的多数群体的一员而被敲打。当人们不能感到舒适，当人们不能感到他们将要，如果人们觉得他们因为所属的族裔群体而在这些课程中受到攻击，那么人们就无法学习。
And what I tend to do is use myself as someone, let me share my experiences around what I learned about myself and the biases being a baby boomer growing up in the 60s that I became aware of, that I needed to work on. And that allows people sitting there in your class to have their own introspection, if you will, right? to look inside themselves. And as I'm sharing my experience, people are having their own personal experience around something maybe they could have done better, said better, or took a different attitude or approach about. But I think people get more value out of that than as opposed to me pointing them out or making them tell me something that you did, you know, was biased and it was unfair.
我倾向于做的是利用我自己作为某个人，让我分享我在60年代成长为婴儿潮一代时学到的关于我自己和偏见的经历，我意识到我需要努力改进。这让坐在你课堂上的人能够进行他们自己的内省，如果可以的话，对吧？向内审视自己。当我分享我的经历时，人们会对他们可能做得更好、说得更好或采取不同态度或方法的事情有自己的个人体验。但我认为人们从中得到的价值比我指出他们或让他们告诉我你做过的某件偏见且不公平的事情要多。
And that's a process people have to have within themselves. And if they feel comfortable enough to share it on their own, great. But I don't push people into that. I just share my experience, which I think allow people the freedom to sit there and have their own conversation with themselves. So you must feel then that there's some value to this. I mean, even if it doesn't completely eradicate implicit bias, I mean, you're obviously teaching these courses, presumably to police all.
这是一个人们必须在内心进行的过程。如果他们觉得足够舒服可以自己分享，那很好。但我不会强迫人们这样做。我只是分享我的经历，我认为这让人们有自由坐在那里与自己进行对话。所以你一定觉得这有某种价值。我的意思是，即使它不能完全根除内隐偏见，我的意思是，你显然在教授这些课程，大概是教给所有警察。
officers. I mean, how does, I mean, just the self-awareness, do you feel that that by itself is worth the effort? That by itself, yes, that by itself is huge. The fact that it brings a level of consciousness, right? It brings people up to a level of consciousness, a self-awareness that they themselves may be struggling and maybe to talk to someone else they feel comfortable with, but not in a classroom of 20, 30 folks, right? But the whole idea is to make you aware. Here is my experience. Here's what I had to learn about things that I was taught in the 60s, about people, about places, about things. And I later learn as a public servant if I'm going to serve a diverse group of people in our society. And here again, not just in diverse in terms of the obvious of black and
警官。我的意思是，仅仅是自我意识，你觉得这本身就值得努力吗？这本身，是的，这本身就是巨大的。它带来了一种意识水平，对吧？它使人们达到一种自我意识水平，即他们自己可能正在挣扎，也许可以与他们感到舒服的其他人交谈，而不是在20、30人的教室里，对吧？但整个想法是让你意识到。这是我的经历。这是我必须学习的关于我在60年代被教导的关于人、关于地点、关于事物的事情。后来我作为一名公务员了解到，如果我要服务于我们社会中一个多元化的群体。而且这里再次强调，不仅仅是在黑人和
white male or female, but understanding people think about things different. People process things differently. People come from different cultures, different backgrounds, different families, different orientations. We have generational differences, which is one that is often overlooked in biases that we may have. Well, I'm a baby bomber. This is how we did it. This is the only right way to do it. Well, I just lost the attention of any millennial, any generation X, Y, Z, or otherwise, right? Because their reality is not my reality. And it's just important that we're aware and knowledgeable of the fact that our way is not always perceived that way by others in terms of how we think and feel and look at the world. Not long ago you had an op-ed published in the Washington Post
白人男性或女性的明显方面多元化，而是理解人们对事物的思考方式不同。人们处理事物的方式不同。人们来自不同的文化、不同的背景、不同的家庭、不同的取向。我们有代际差异，这是我们在可能拥有的偏见中经常被忽视的一个。好吧，我是婴儿潮一代。这就是我们做事的方式。这是唯一正确的做事方式。好吧，我刚刚失去了任何千禧一代、任何X、Y、Z世代或其他人的注意力，对吧？因为他们的现实不是我的现实。重要的是我们要意识到并了解这样一个事实，即我们的方式并不总是被其他人以我们思考、感受和看待世界的方式所感知。不久前你有一篇专栏文章发表在《华盛顿邮报》上
about the importance of selecting the right people to be police officers. What do you think needs to change in how we recruit and select officers? Well, I think the whole construct around policing needs to be challenged to meet the needs of a 21st century society, diverse society that we live in. We need to take a look at who it is that we are recruiting. We need to make sure that we recruit men and women. who truly value differences and can embrace diversity. And even though none of us can be responsible,
关于选择合适的人担任警官的重要性。你认为我们在招募和选拔警官的方式上需要改变什么？嗯，我认为围绕警务的整个结构需要受到挑战，以满足我们所生活的21世纪社会、多元化社会的需求。我们需要看看我们正在招募谁。我们需要确保我们招募男男女女。他们真正重视差异并能拥抱多样性。即使我们没有人能负责，
what city, town, rural area, metropolitan area, we were born and raised in. We can't pick our families. We can't pick families that are going to teach us to be loving and kind. We can't pick families who are going to be bigoted. We can't pick those families. We're born into those families, wherever they may happen to be, into those communities. But the day that we become adults, the day that we go into public service, we have to take on the responsibility of whatever did not happen for us and to us, it's now our responsibility.
我们在哪个城市、城镇、农村地区、大都市地区出生和长大。我们不能选择我们的家庭。我们不能选择那些会教导我们要充满爱心和善良的家庭。我们不能选择那些会偏执的家庭。我们不能选择那些家庭。无论它们可能在哪里，我们都出生在那些家庭中，进入那些社区。但当我们成为成年人的那一天，当我们进入公共服务的那一天，我们必须承担起责任，无论什么没有为我们发生，现在是我们的责任。
It must be become adults. So I think it becomes important that we seek out men and women who value differences, who value diversity. and even if they grew up in rural Idaho, and they never saw anybody other than people who looked like themselves, who had the same social values as themselves, but they have a willingness and an openness and a desire to go beyond what they know
必须成为成年人。所以我认为寻找重视差异、重视多样性的男男女女变得很重要。即使他们是在爱达荷州的农村长大的，他们从未见过除了看起来像自己的人、拥有相同社会价值观的人之外的任何人，但他们有一种意愿、一种开放和一种渴望去超越他们所知道的
and to experience things that they may have not been able to experience because none of us can help where we're born. But do you have our open heart? Do you have a willingness to serve all people, all kinds of people? Here again, not the obvious, but all kinds of people, people who can embrace those differences. That become hugely important. And not police officers who are going to show at, but a January 6th insurrection and be there as police officers standing next to someone who hate Jews or someone who hates other groups of people that demonstrate. that in the paraphernalia that they wear, and certainly that wasn't indicative of everybody there.
并去体验他们可能无法体验的事情，因为我们没有人能选择我们在哪里出生。但你有一颗开放的心吗？你有一种服务所有人、各种各样的人的意愿吗？这里再次强调，不是明显的，而是各种各样的人，能够拥抱这些差异的人。这变得非常重要。而不是那些会出现在1月6日叛乱中，作为警官站在仇恨犹太人的人或仇恨其他群体的人旁边，并展示出这一点的人。
But how would you think of me, Kim, if you saw me as a police officer show up on January 6th, standing and bracing some guy with a Nazi t-shirt on? And then I'm supposed to come back into your community, and you have a sense of trust in me. It ain't happening. So how do you root that out then during the recruitment and selection? It means we have to, and I've written about this, we have to dig deeper. It means that we just don't look at their credit history or their driving record. We got to go beyond those basic things.
在他们穿戴的装备中，当然那并不代表那里的每个人。但是，金，如果你看到我作为一名警官出现在1月6日，站在那里拥抱一个穿着纳粹T恤的家伙，你会怎么想我？然后我应该回到你的社区，而你对我有一种信任感。这不可能发生。那么你如何在招募和选拔过程中根除这一点呢？这意味着我们必须，我已经写过关于这个的文章，我们必须挖掘得更深。这意味着我们不仅仅看他们的信用记录或驾驶记录。我们必须超越那些基本的东西。
We got to go deeper into who you are and more about your history, more about who your affiliations, who you associate with. If you're on social media, we need to look deep into your social media profiles, see who you associate. and align yourselves with and look for things that could be telling. It's the same type of in-depth investigation that our federal law enforcement is able to do. Right. Sounds like a security clearance, right? Yeah. Yeah, almost like a security clearance. Now, that is expensive. And of course, federal law enforcement is much smaller than many of your municipal agencies that are much larger. but the fact that the matter is that's the type of detail we need to start seeking out.
我们必须更深入地了解你是谁，更多地了解你的历史，更多地了解你的从属关系，你与谁交往。如果你在社交媒体上，我们需要深入查看你的社交媒体资料，看看你与谁交往，并与谁结盟，并寻找可能说明问题的迹象。这与我们的联邦执法部门能够做的那种深入调查是一样的。对。听起来像安全审查，对吧？是的。是的，几乎像安全审查。现在，这很昂贵。当然，联邦执法部门比你们许多规模大得多的市政机构要小得多。但事实是，这就是我们需要开始寻找的那种细节。
But now, after we find individuals who meet the criteria, who understand and respect differences and who are capable going into any community and doing a good job, now we have to train them. We have to go back and look at our training protocols, make sure that certainly we're training them to protect themselves and protect the public, but we're also training them that 80% of the calls that they're going to respond to is going to be community relations. They really are. And that's 89% of the work that police officers do. And once we have them trained now, we've got to make sure that we put them with good role models, good mentors, who can demonstrate
但是现在，在我们找到符合标准、理解并尊重差异且有能力进入任何社区并做好工作的个人之后，现在我们必须培训他们。我们必须回去看看我们的培训协议，确保我们当然是在培训他们保护自己和保护公众，但我们也在培训他们，他们将要响应的80%的电话将是社区关系。确实如此。这是警官所做工作的89%。一旦我们培训了他们，我们必须确保我们将他们与优秀的榜样、优秀的导师放在一起，他们可以展示
everything that they've learned in an academy setting. They can demonstrate how. to apply it out in the communities on the streets in which they serve. And you have to have healthy police environments as well so that when they become part of that larger culture, they know that inside that culture, there are expectations that we all will live by. And it's going to be to service this community and not for our own personal selves. So there's some things that have to be rewritten, redone. It's going to take time. But if we want to build trust and legitimacy in this country, it certainly is going to take us doing a far better job than what we have in the past.
他们在学院环境中学习到的一切。他们可以展示如何将它应用到他们所服务的社区和街道上。你还必须拥有健康的警察环境，这样当他们成为那个更大文化的一部分时，他们知道在那个文化内部，有我们所有人都将遵守的期望。这将是为了服务这个社区，而不是为了我们自己的个人利益。所以有些事情必须重写、重做。这需要时间。但如果我们想在这个国家建立信任和合法性，这当然需要我们做得比过去好得多。
Another topic of discussion around police reform is how officers respond to people in mental health crisis. And when you were the police chief in Rochester, you implement. a mental health training program for officers. And other cities have begun to experiment with sending mental health specialists with police to respond on these kinds of calls. Is that the right way? Is that a good model for police departments to approach around the country? Well, I think, you know, if we're going to talk reform and reimagining police,
围绕警察改革的另一个讨论话题是警官如何应对处于心理健康危机中的人。当你担任罗切斯特警察局长时，你实施了一个针对警官的心理健康培训计划。其他城市也开始尝试派遣心理健康专家与警察一起响应这类电话。这是正确的方法吗？这是警察部门在全国范围内采取的一个好模式吗？嗯，我认为，你知道，如果我们谈论改革和重新构想警察，
I think it would be an opportunity at this point to begin to think about redefining what the roles and calls for service we want police to respond to. And I think we need to narrow the scope of calls for service police. We need to stop sending them to homelessness and mental health and dog barking complaint calls. We need a narrow scope of what it is that they do. And then we need to hire people who are also housed in those public safety facilities who are able to respond to those calls. Now, if you respond to a mental health call and someone is a severe threat to themselves of someone else, yes, you need to send a police officer with that trained clinician. The key here would be how do we address mental illness in our community so it does not run out of control?
我认为现在是一个机会，开始考虑重新定义我们希望警察响应的角色和呼叫服务。我认为我们需要缩小警察呼叫服务的范围。我们需要停止派遣他们去处理无家可归、心理健康和狗叫投诉电话。我们需要缩小他们所做工作的范围。然后我们需要雇佣那些也安置在这些公共安全设施中的人，他们能够响应这些电话。现在，如果你响应一个心理健康电话，而某人对自己或他人构成严重威胁，是的，你需要派遣一名警官和那名受过训练的临床医生。这里的关键将是我们如何解决我们社区中的精神疾病，使其不会失控？
How do we get out ahead of this? How do we identify communities? How do we identify homelessness where you're going to find 80, 90 percent of people who are, who are homeless have some type of DSM-5 diagnosis, right? So how do we try to get out ahead of some of that? Because all the burden and the woes and the ills in this nation, whether it's around schools, lead poisoning, unemployment, poor housing, mental illness, homelessness, whatever,
我们如何走在前面？我们如何识别社区？我们如何识别无家可归，你会发现80%、90%无家可归的人都有某种DSM-5诊断，对吧？所以我们如何尝试走在其中一些问题的前面？因为这个国家所有的负担、苦难和弊病，无论是关于学校、铅中毒、失业、住房条件差、精神疾病、无家可归，无论是什么，
gets dumped into the lapse of our police officers who are not trained to men. all of those different types of things. And we got to find a way to, when we think about reimagining and reforming police, how do we do it in a way that people in those communities, whatever they're struggling with, get those to respond who are better trained to give them the attention and the direction that they need to get help. Defunding the police is a terminology that came about
都被倾倒在没有受过训练去处理所有这些不同类型事情的警官的膝盖上。我们必须找到一种方法，当我们考虑重新构想和改革警察时，我们如何以一种让那些社区中的人们，无论他们正在为什么而挣扎，得到那些受过更好训练的人的响应，给他们他们需要的关注和指导以获得帮助。削减警察经费是一个术语，出现在
right after floor, let's take all the police money away. Well, you can't do that. We don't need to defund police. We need to take a look at policing and take a deep dive look at to what is it that we really want our police department doing. What is it we really want them responding to? But we need to fund them. We need to make sure that they are paid well. They have good benefits. They have retirement that doesn't force them to stay there for 30 or 40 years because many of the stressors that are associated with the type of work that they do is very different probably than many other professions. And we need to make sure that they are well taken care of if we're going to ask them to do these jobs in which they have to make decisions in the moment. And we want to make
弗洛伊德事件之后，让我们拿走所有的警察资金。嗯，你不能那样做。我们不需要削减警察经费。我们需要审视警务工作，深入研究我们真正希望我们的警察部门做什么。我们真正希望他们响应什么？但我们需要资助他们。我们需要确保他们薪水优厚。他们有很好的福利。他们有退休金，不会强迫他们在那里工作30或40年，因为与他们所做工作类型相关的许多压力源可能与许多其他职业非常不同。如果我们要求他们做这些必须在瞬间做出决定的工作，我们需要确保他们得到很好的照顾。我们想要做出
sure we better train them, better prepared them, and that they go out and do what really we wanted police to do from the beginning, and that is prevention. How do we help prevent crime, as opposed always responding? But every social ill in this country gets dumped on policing as opposed to us beginning to, and what we have to begin to do is think about what other professionals we bring into public safety. That's part of the overall. public safety piece because public safety is just not about law enforcement. Public safety is also led free schools and housing. Public safety is also having adequate mental health facilities and supports available to people, dealing with homelessness, dealing with all these things that are public concern
当然，我们最好能培训他们，让他们做好更充分的准备，让他们走出去，做我们从一开始就希望警察做的事情，那就是预防。我们如何帮助预防犯罪，而不是总是做出反应？但这个国家的每一个社会弊病都被推给了警务部门，而不是让我们开始思考，我们必须开始思考，我们还能引入哪些其他专业人员参与公共安全。这是整体公共安全的一部分，因为公共安全不仅仅是关于执法。公共安全也包括免费的学校和住房。公共安全还包括为人们提供充足的心理健康设施和支持，处理无家可归问题，处理所有这些属于公共关注的问题。
in our communities. They are public safety as well. And we have to begin to to look at this in a very different way than what we have in the past. Last question, just to wrap up, what do you think are the most important things that police departments need to do to regain the trust of their communities, especially in those communities where the trust is so broken? Well, yeah. So every day, every, and I used to tell police officers this, every call for service you go on, there are people out there that you're going to interface with who have never interface with the police in their life. And whatever impression that we need is might be the only
在我们的社区中。它们也是公共安全的一部分。我们必须开始以一种与过去完全不同的方式来看待这个问题。最后一个问题，总结一下，你认为警察部门为了重新获得社区的信任，特别是那些信任已经破裂的社区的信任，最需要做的事情是什么？嗯，是的。所以每一天，每一个，我过去常告诉警察，你接到的每一个服务电话，你都会接触到那些一生中从未与警察打过交道的人。而我们留下的任何印象，可能就是他们唯一的
impression that they know. It's like doing public relations. You know, it's an every day we go to work. We're building trusts. You know, every day that we go to work, we have to role model what we, what we say we are, right? Professional public safety servants. And we have to do everything that we can to build trust in those relationships because if you go back historically over time with policing in this country and people of color, it has always been in this place of discontent because policing started out at slave patrols. It came up through Jim Crow, civil rights, keeping black folks on certain sides of town as directed by elected officials. And police have not always been there to serve communities of color historically the way that they have other
他们所知道的印象。这就像做公共关系。你知道，我们每天去上班。我们都在建立信任。你知道，我们每天去上班，都必须以身作则，展现我们所宣称的形象，对吧？专业的公共安全服务人员。我们必须尽一切努力在这些关系中建立信任，因为如果你回顾这个国家的警务历史以及有色人种的经历，它一直处于不满的状态，因为警务工作始于奴隶巡逻队。它经历了吉姆·克劳法时期、民权运动，在民选官员的指示下，将黑人限制在城镇的特定区域。从历史上看，警察并不总是像对待其他社区那样服务有色人种社区。
communities. And even though we like to think that we have made significant gains over the years, and I truly believe that we have, we still got a tremendous amount of work to do. Because every time we have an incident in this country that creates a great deal of attention and pause and concern, we have to try to manage each one of those cases in a way that people feel that fairness and justice for everybody involved. It's an ongoing relationship building. You never get to an endpoint. It's just something you're constantly building every day. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Alexander. You certainly have given us a lot to think about, and we have a lot of work yet in front of us. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you for having.
社区。尽管我们愿意认为多年来我们已经取得了重大进展，而且我真心相信我们确实取得了进展，但我们仍有大量工作要做。因为每当这个国家发生一起引起极大关注、停顿和担忧的事件时，我们都必须设法以一种让人们感到对所有相关人员都公平和公正的方式来处理每一个案件。这是一种持续的关系建设。你永远不会达到终点。这只是你每天都在不断构建的东西。好吧，感谢您今天加入我们，亚历山大博士。您确实给了我们很多思考的空间，我们面前还有很多工作要做。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢您的邀请。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www. www.spokenof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please, if you can, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne.
您可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果可以的话，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，加上 @apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condyenne。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。